Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the vaulted archway of the museum's grand gallery. He lunged for the nearest painting he could see, a Caravaggio. Grabbing the gilded frame, the 76-year-old man heaved the masterpiece toward himself until it tore from the wall and Sonier collapsed backward in a heap beneath the canvas. As he had anticipated, a thundering iron gate fell nearby, barricading the entrance to the suite. The parquet floor shook. Far off, an alarm began to ring.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，加入博物馆宏伟大厅的拱形回廊。他朝着视线内最近的一幅画作——一幅卡拉瓦乔的作品——猛扑过去。这位 76 岁的老人抓住镀金画框，奋力将这件杰作朝自己拽去，直到它从墙上撕裂脱落，索尼埃随后在一片混乱中向后倒在画布下方。正如他所预料的那样，一扇沉重的铁栅栏门在附近轰然落下，封锁了套房的入口。拼花地板震动起来。远处，警报器开始鸣响。
The curator lay a moment, gasping for breath, taking stock. I am still alive. He crawled out from under the canvas and scanned the cavernous space for some place to hide. A voice spoke, chillingly close. Do not move. On his hands and knees, the curator froze, turning his head slowly.
馆长在地上躺了一会儿，大口喘着粗气，审视着周围的情况。我还活着。他从画布底下爬出来，扫视着这个洞穴般宽敞的空间，寻找藏身之处。一个声音响了起来，近得让人骨头发冷。不许动。馆长双手双膝着地，一动不动地僵在那里，缓缓转过头去。
And that, renowned historian Tom Holland, is how the Da Vinci Code opened when it was published 20 years ago in 2003. A great literary landmark, Tom. Yeah. One of the great anniversaries.
著名历史学家汤姆·霍兰，20 年前的 2003 年，《达芬奇密码》出版时就是这样开场的。一部伟大的文学里程碑，汤姆。是的。这是一个伟大的周年纪念。
And Dominic, if I may say. Yes. Hugely enhanced there by your reading. Oh, thank you. Your accents were tip top. Well, I don't know whether, does Dan Brown do his own reading? I don't imagine he does somehow.
多米尼克，如果我可以这么说的话。是的。你刚才的朗读大大增色了。噢，谢谢你。你的口音非常地道。嗯，我不知道，丹·布朗是自己录有声书吗？我想他大概不会吧。
I don't know, but I thought the accent you gave to the 76-year-old man was very, very good. Yes. Well, I think that's a lovely bit of description there because there's already, Dan Brown starts that book with the words renowned curator.
我不知道，但我认为你给那个 76 岁老人的口音非常非常棒。是的。嗯，我觉得那是一段非常精彩的描写，因为丹·布朗在一开始就用了“著名馆长”这个词。
Yeah. So he starts with an occupation and the person's level within his profession, which I think I admire. And then the next time he refers to that person, he thinks that the best way to describe him is the 76 year old man. Because the reader knows he's a renowned curator, but the obvious question, how old is he? And Dan Brown sorts that out immediately. And is he a man? I man i mean you think man is the right noun to go for there we've already had he i think his pronouns are clear um but uh yes so he and and the person behind him is an albino monk right yeah it's an albino monk who is working for opus
对。所以他从一个人的职业和他在行业中的级别切入，我觉得这很令人钦佩。然后下一次他指代这个人的时候，他认为最好的描述方式就是“那个 76 岁的老人”。因为读者已经知道他是个著名的馆长，但显而易见的问题是：他多大年纪？丹·布朗立刻就解决了这个问题。而且他是个男人吗？我是说，你觉得“男人”是那里最合适的称呼吗？我们前面已经用过“他”了，我觉得他的代词很明确，嗯……但是，是的，所以他——而他身后的人是一个白化病僧侣，对吧？是的，是一个为“主业会”工作的白化病僧侣。
day so you'll know all about opus day tom opus day it's a very very uh hardcore catholic organization isn't it and they tie kind of spikes around their thighs and tighten them nice yes yeah um you're not doing that right now i can't see i can only see the top half of you you're not wearing spikes on your thighs are you i'm not i'm not a member of opus day um but you have read the da vinci you read it didn't you when did you read it when it came out yes we'd set aside the day to do gardening uh say you've been very strict about this i came in about 11 for you know a cup of tea picked it up read that opening paragraph yeah well it is kind of brilliant. I mean, it's in the Louvre. There's a renowned curator. He's pulling down paintings as an albino monk. He dies as symbols. And before you know it, you're on this incredible adventure that reaches all the way back to the time of Jesus and conspiracy spanning 2000 years. and I found it completely page turning. I mean, obviously, everybody says
所以你对“主业会”（Opus Dei）一定很了解了，汤姆。“主业会”是一个非常非常核心正统的天主教组织，对吧？他们会在大腿上绑上那种尖刺，然后把它勒紧，是啊。嗯，你现在没在绑这个吧？我看不见，我只能看到你的上半身。你大腿上没绑刺吧？我没有，我又不是“主业会”的成员。不过你读过《达芬奇密码》，你读过的，对吧？你是什么时候读的？是它刚出来的时候吗？对，我们当时专门腾出一天时间来做园艺——说得好像你对这事很严格似的——我大概 11 点左右进来喝杯茶，拿起了这本书，读了开头的那段。嗯，确实挺精彩的。我是说，故事发生在卢浮宫。有个著名的馆长。他拉下画作，有个白化病僧侣。他留着暗号死去。不知不觉中，你就踏上了一场不可思议的冒险，一直追溯到耶稣时代，以及长达两千年的阴谋。我发现这本书简直让人爱不释手。我是说，显然，人人都说
the prose is awful and there are huge undigested chunks of Wikipedia scattered everywhere. But it is unbelievably readable. I read it in three hours and ignored all Sadie's importunate demands
它的文笔糟糕透顶，里面塞满了各种从维基百科上生搬硬套来的大段大段未经消化的资料。但它真的好读得不可思议。我三个小时就读完了，完全不理会赛迪那些不合时宜的要求，
that I go out to. Dig the potatoes or whatever. But you haven't read it. No, I have read it now. And what did you think? Did you not find it gripping? I didn't really because I knew where it was going. I knew too much about it.
叫我出去挖马铃薯什么的。不过你还没读过吧？不，我现在已经读过了。你觉得怎么样？难道你不觉得引人入胜吗？我其实没这种感觉，因为我知道剧情会走向何方。我对它了解得太多了。
So there was no sense of mystery. But Dominic. Yeah. As I was reading it, I also knew where it was going. And the reason for that is that it very clearly, I think, draws on a book that I had read when I was maybe 12, 13. So it came out in the early 80s called The Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, which presents this theory that Jesus didn't die on the cross, that he came with Mary Magdalene to the south of France, as one does's retired there, you know, retirement villa. And he established a bloodline, which is being guarded by a sinister organization called the Priory of Zion.
所以完全没有那种神秘感。但是，多米尼克。嗯。我在读的时候，其实也知道它会走向何方。原因在于，我认为它非常明显地借鉴了我大概在 12、13 岁时读过的一本书。那是 80 年代初出版的，名叫《圣血与圣杯》（The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail）。这本书提出了一种理论：耶稣并没有死在十字架上，而是和抹大拉的玛丽亚一起来到了法国南部——就像人们常做的那样，在那里安度晚年，你知道的，买了一栋退休别墅。他在那里建立了一个血脉，而这个血脉正由一个名为“锡安会”（Priory of Sion）的阴谋组织所守护。
And as I remember, at the beginning, at the opening of the Da Vinci Code, Dan Brown, before he's even got into his narrative, states that the Priory of Zion is a real organization. And he says that it's a secret society
我记得在《达芬奇密码》的开篇，丹·布朗甚至还没进入正文，就声称“锡安会”是一个真实的组织。他说这是一个秘密社团，
founded very specifically in 1099. Yes, he does. So he has a little section called Facts. And he says, all descriptions of artwork, architecture, documents, and secret rituals in this novel are accurate. And beneath that, it says, the Priory of Zion,
而且非常具体地成立于 1099 年。是的，他是这么说的。所以他有一个名为“事实”的小节。他说：“小说中对所有艺术品、建筑、文献以及秘密仪式的描述皆属准确。”而在那行字下方写着：“锡安会”——
a European secret society founded in 1099, is a real organization. In 1975, Paris's Bibliothèque Nationale discovered parchments known as les dossiers secrets, identifying numerous members of the Priory of Sion, including Sir Isaac Newton, Botticelli,or hugo and leonardo da vinci hence the name and that those documents are what is also inspired the writing of the holy blood and the holy grail well this is there's an amazing detective story here which we should have some fun with i will just say this of course da vinci is not leonardo's surname so um according to da vinci code is slightly questionable but but under sort of lying all this so dan brown Vinci is not Leonardo's surname. No. So calling it the Da Vinci Code is slightly questionable. But under sort of lying all this. So Dan Brown.
一个成立于 1099 年的欧洲秘密社团，是一个真实的组织。1975 年，巴黎国家图书馆发现了被称为“秘密档案”（les dossiers secrets）的羊皮纸文献，其中确定了“锡安会”的众多成员，包括艾萨克·牛顿爵士、波提切利、维克多·雨果和列奥纳多·达·芬奇（这也是该组织名称的由来），并且这些文献也是启发《圣血与圣杯》创作的源泉。这里有一个惊人的侦探故事，我们应该好好挖掘一下。我只想说，达芬奇当然不是列奥纳多的姓氏，所以……根据《达芬奇密码》的说法，这一点稍微有点存疑。但这一切的背后，丹·布朗——达芬奇不是列奥纳多的姓氏。对。所以把它叫做《达芬奇密码》有点存疑。但这一切的背后，丹·布朗。
Dan Brown is not just anybody, Tom. Dan Brown, you know I'm fascinated by what schools people went to, a running theme. Did he go to your school? He did not. Like the former head of the CIA? Like James Jesus Angleton, the CIA counterintelligence chief. No, he did not, unfortunately for him.
丹·布朗可不是一般人，汤姆。丹·布朗——你知道我对人们上过什么学校很着迷，这是一个贯穿始终的主题。他去过你的学校吗？他没有。就像中情局前局长那样？就像中情局反情报主管詹姆斯·热苏斯·安格尔顿（James Jesus Angleton）那样？不，他没有，对他来说真是不幸。
But he did go to probably the, well, one of the two or three most prestigious boarding schools in America. So people always think of boarding schools as uniquely British, but actually there are boarding schools in America on a British model. And when you go through the list of their alumni, you realize what colossal monsters of the American elite actually were not educated in the world of high schools and proms and, you know, sort of people driving to school and all that sort of 1950s white picket fence fantasy of the
不过他确实去过可以说是——嗯，全美最负盛名的两三所寄宿学校之一。所以人们总是认为寄宿学校是英国独有的，但实际上美国也有仿照英国模式建立的寄宿学校。当你翻看他们的校友名录时，你就会意识到，美国精英阶层中那些庞然大物，其实根本不是在那种高中、毕业舞会的世界里受教育的——你知道的，那种人们开车去上学、充满 1950 年代白栅栏美式高中幻想的世界。他们上的是寄宿学校。
American high school. They went to boarding schools. So Dan Brown went to this place called Phillips Exeter Academy. And these boarding schools are like kind of Eton? They're exactly like that. They wear uniforms and boaters and rowing and all that kind of stuff. Lots of rowing. So Phillips Exeter Academy, which is where Dan Brown went, is very much a rowing school. Mark Zuckerberg went to Dan Brown's school. U.S. President Franklin Pierce went to it.
所以丹·布朗去了菲利普斯埃克塞特学院（Phillips Exeter Academy）。这些寄宿学校有点像伊顿公学吗？完全就是那个样子的。他们穿制服、戴硬草帽、划船，诸如此类。有大量的划船活动。所以菲利普斯埃克塞特学院——也就是丹·布朗读过的学校——非常像是一所划船学校。马克·扎克伯格就去了丹·布朗的学校。美国总统富兰克林·皮尔斯也去过。
Ulysses Grant sent his son there. Lots of generals, lots of diplomats. So Dan Brown leaves his school. He spends a lot of time. He wears these sort of fawn polo necks, which I don't defend. And he tries to be a composer, and that doesn't work out. And he decides to be a renowned writer. Well, he is a renowned writer.
尤利西斯·格兰特把他的儿子送到了那里。有大量的将军，大量的外交官。所以丹·布朗离开了他的学校。他花了很长时间。他穿着那种黄褐色高领衫，这我可不敢苟同。他曾试图成为一名作曲家，但没成功。于是他决定成为一名著名的作家。好吧，他确实是一位著名的作家。
Well, he is. Yeah. He's in our podcast, Tom. That's the marker of fame. Right. So his first book was Angels and Demons. That's the first book that involves the top Harvard puzzle solver, Robert Langdon. He's a symbologist, isn't he?
嗯，他确实是。是的。他现在出现在我们的播客里了，汤姆。这就是成名的标志。没错。所以他的第一本书是《天使与恶魔》（Angels and Demons）。那是第一本涉及哈佛顶尖解谜专家罗伯特·兰登的书。他是个符号学专家，对吧？
A symbologist. Is that a real thing? There are quite a lot of them in the Da Vinci Code. So he wrote the Da Vinci Code in 2003, and it sold 81 million copies. And the only book that outsold it was the latest Harry Potter book. So it's obviously a tremendous hit. And the thread that runs through the story. So it's a Lee Teabing,
符号学专家。这真的是个职业吗？《达芬奇密码》里有相当多这样的人。所以他在 2003 年写了《达芬奇密码》，卖出了 8100 万册。唯一一本销量超过它的书是最新的《哈利·波特》。所以这显然是一个巨大的轰动。而贯穿这个故事的线索——也就是雷·提宾（Lee Teabing），
who is one of the great characters of the story. He's very proud to say British, isn't he? Yes, he is British. He explains, he explains that Jesus Christ got together with Mary Magdalene. So she's at his right hand,
他是故事中的伟大角色之一。他非常自豪地宣称自己是个英国人，对吧？是的，他是英国人。他解释说——他解释说耶稣基督和抹大拉的玛丽亚走到了一起。所以她在他的右手边，
I think in the last supper, he says, being painted there deliberately because they were a couple and they got married and had children. And Salih Teabing says, the early church feared that if the lineage was permitted to grow, the secret of Jesus and Magdalene would eventually surface and challenge the fundamental Catholic doctrine, that of a divine Messiah who did not consort with women or engage in sexual union. So he says Christ's bloodline is hidden in the south of France when Christ's bloodline
我想在《最后的晚餐》中，她之所以被刻意画在那里，是因为他们是一对情侣，他们结了婚并有了孩子。雷·提宾说：“早期教会担心，如果这一血脉得以延续，耶稣和玛丽亚的秘密终将浮出水面，并对天主教的核心教义构成挑战——即神圣的弥赛亚不与女性厮混，也不参与性结合。”所以他说基督的血脉被隐藏在法国南部，当时基督的血脉
makes a bold move in the fifth century. As bloodlines do. Can a bloodline... Yeah, exactly. The bloodline's attacking me. When intermarried with French royal blood and created a lineage known as the Merovingian bloodline. Now, the Merovingians, Tom, this is absolutely your turf. So who are the Merovingians? So the Merovingians are the dynasty founded by Clovis. So Clovis is a Frankish warlord who, at the end of the 5th century, the Roman Empire in Gaul has imploded.
在公元 5 世纪采取了一个大胆的举动。血脉还会这么做吗？血脉难道能……对，没错。血脉在攻击我。当它与法国皇室血统通婚时，便创造了一个被称为“墨洛温王朝”（Merovingian bloodline）的血脉。现在，墨洛温家族，汤姆，这绝对是你的专业领域。那么，墨洛温家族是谁？墨洛温家族是由克洛维（Clovis）建立的王朝。所以克洛维是一个法兰克人的军阀，在 5 世纪末，罗马帝国在加利亚（高卢）的统治已经崩溃。
There are kind of various tribal entities that are emerging. Clovis basically annexes vast swathes of them and he is I mean he's kind of commemorated as the first king of France which is an anachronistic way of putting it but of course the name France comes from the Franks so there's an element of truth in it um and the other key thing that Clovis is remembered for is that at a time where most of the barbarian warlords are Christian but they are not Catholic um They subscribe to a heresy called Arianism, in which the son is inferior to the father rather than being. So it's a different understanding of the Trinity. Clovis subscribes to the Catholic tradition. And so he is commemorated by the Catholic Church as a kind of a model of what a king should be. And he establishes this line of kings, the Merovingians. So they claim descent from, I think, a merman. So a kind of an aquatic entity.
当时涌现出了各种各样的部族实体。克洛维基本上吞并了其中广袤的领土，他被——我的意思是，他被当做法兰克的第一位国王来纪念，这是一种时代错置的说法，但“法兰克”（France）这个名字确实来源于法兰克人（Franks），所以其中也包含了一定成分的真理。嗯，人们记住克洛维的另一个关键原因是，在大多数蛮族军阀都是基督徒但并非天主教徒的时期——
So they don't hold the same view of themselves that Dan Brown holds of them as i remember the merman there's some i think it's waving in somehow i can't remember but um the other thing that characterizes them is that they have a long hair right a bit like samson in the old testament this long hair is a marker of their strength and so when in due course the merovingians become ever more kind of spectral as kings and power passes to the line of men who are serving them as their right-hand man, their court chamberlain. And in due course, this family deposes the Merovingians. And this is the dynasty that historians call the Carolingians, of whom the most famous member is Charlemagne. The last of the Merovingians who gets deposed,
他们信奉一种名为“阿里乌斯派”（Arianism）的异端，在该派看来，子次于父，而不是与父同等。所以这是对三位一体的不同理解。而克洛维信奉的是天主教传统。因此，他被天主教教会奉为国王应有模范的一种象征。他建立了这一脉国王，即墨洛温王朝。所以他们声称自己是——我想——一个海神的后代。也就是一种水生实体。
he is a guy called Childeric, Childeric III, and he has his long hair shaved off in a kind of monastic tonsure and he gets put in a monastery and that's him. And that's the end of the Merovingians.
所以他们对自己的看法，和丹·布朗对他们的看法并不一样。我记得那个海神，好像有什么——我记不清了，但——嗯，他们的另一个特征是他们留着长发，有点像旧约里的参孙。这长发是他们力量的象征。因此，随着时间的推移，墨洛温诸王变得越来越像虚有其表的幽灵，权力转移到了那些作为他们得力助手、宫廷总管的人手中。随后，这个家族废黜了墨洛温家族。这就是历史学家所称的“加洛林王朝”（Carolingians），其中最著名的成员就是查理曼大帝。最后一个被废黜的墨洛温国王，
Or is it? Or is it? You see, because the Dan Brown, the arguments of the Da Vinci Code, it just occurred to me, Tom, are we not all descended from mermen, ultimately? I suppose we are
是一个叫希尔德里克三世（Childeric III）的人，他标志性的长发被剃掉了，剃成了修士的圆顶发式，然后被关进了一座修道院里，他的故事就到此为止了。这就是墨洛温王朝的终结。
in a manner of speaking. In a manner of speaking. Yes, we are. The Pale the paleozoic with your knowledge of science you'll know all about that um so dan brown's argument is the merovingians did not die out that there was a merovingian called daggerbert ii he was murdered in shady circumstances and became a bit of a martyr bit of a sort of folk hero and he secretly had a son called Sigisbert, and the line of descent goes down and it goes down to the present. And it's been guarded all this time by this organization, the Secret Society. A series of secret societies in some ways,
真的是这样吗？真的是这样吗？你看，因为丹·布朗——《达芬奇密码》中的那些论点，我刚刚突然想到，汤姆，难道我们最终不都是海神的后代吗？我想是的，
because there's hints of the Templars, the simps of another group called the Cathars, which we will come to in a second. But the Priory of Sion is the key one. And 1099, because that's when the Crusaders capture Jerusalem. Exactly. And it's kind of associated with all that. Now, and if you have, if listeners who have not read The Da Vinci Code
从某种意义上说。从某种意义上说。是的，我们是。古生代时期——以你对科学的了解，你肯定对这个很熟悉。嗯，所以丹·布朗的论点是，墨洛温家族并没有消亡，其中有一个叫达戈贝尔特二世（Dagobert II）的墨洛温人，他在可疑的情况下被谋杀，变成了一个殉道者、某种民间英雄。他秘密地留下了一个儿子叫西吉伯特（Sigisbert），这一脉血脉一直流传下来，一直延续到了今天。而且这么长时间以来，它一直受到这个组织、这个秘密社团的守护。从某种程度上说，这是一系列秘密社团，
have any doubts about the factual accuracy of this, Dan Brown is absolutely adamant. So in 2003, he was promoting the novel. He was asked in interviews which parts of the history are actually true. And he said, and I quote, absolutely all of it. Again, CNN, he's asked how much is it true? He said 99% is true. The background is all true.
因为其中暗示了圣殿骑士团（Templars）、另一个名为“卡特里派”（Cathars）的群体的影子，我们一会儿就会讲到。但“锡安会”才是关键。还有 1099 年，因为那是十字军攻占耶路撒冷的年份。没错。它与这一切都有所关联。现在，如果——如果那些还没读过《达芬奇密码》的听众
And actually, you know what? That idea of Jesus and Mary Magdalene having coupled up, as it were, is not unknown in history, is it, Tom? Well, Dominic, so the reason we're doing this is partly because of the anniversary, but also because actually, although, I mean, it will not surprise the listeners to know that we don't believe any of this. Oh, Tom, what a spoiler. You know, there is no secret bloodline. None of this is true.
对这些内容的真实性有任何怀疑的话，丹·布朗是绝对坚信不疑的。所以在 2003 年，他在宣传这部小说时，在采访中被问及历史的哪一部分是真实的时，他曾说——我引用他的话：“绝对全部都是真的。”不仅如此，在 CNN 节目中，当被问及有多少内容是真实的，他说 99% 都是真的。背景全都是真的。
But the idea of there being some terrible conspiracy, some overarching understanding of history that has been buried and which only certain people have fathomed. And more specifically, yeah, absolutely. The idea that Jesus and convulsive period of medieval history. And so although Dan Brown and all that kind of stuff is wrong, it's wrong in a way that is going with the grain of some very, very fascinating developments in medieval Christendom. And these are the Cathars. That's right, isn't it? They are called the Cathars. So the Templars and the Cathars are very famous. I mean, they would be known by people who otherwise might have no interest in medieval history.
而且，你知道吗？耶稣和抹大拉的玛丽亚结合了——也就是这么个说法——在历史上并不是闻所未闻的，对吧，汤姆？嗯，多米尼克，所以我们今天聊这个，一部分是因为周年纪念，但也是因为，虽然——我的意思是，听众们听到我们并不相信这一切，应该不会感到惊讶。哦，汤姆，你可真是个剧透狂。你知道的，根本没有什么秘密血脉。这些全都是假的。
And they're both famous, I think, because there is the idea that they possess a secret wisdom. Yes. And in both cases, it's associated with the Holy Grail. Yeah. So it's thought that the Templars are guarding the Holy Grail, but in other versions, it's the Cathars who are supposedly, they're centered in the South of France. So the Languedoc,
但关于某种可怕的阴谋、某种被掩埋且只有少数人参透的历史总体认知的想法，却非常有吸引力。更具体地说，是的，绝对是这样。关于耶稣和抹大拉的玛丽亚的想法，其实深深植根于中世纪历史中一个非常动荡的时期。所以，尽管丹·布朗和所有那些东西都是错的，但他的错误却契合了中世纪基督教世界中一些非常非常迷人的发展趋势。这就是卡特里派。对吧？他们被称为卡特里派。所以圣殿骑士团和卡特里派非常有名。我是说，即便那些对中世纪历史毫无兴趣的人也会知道他们。
they are a shadowy counterpart to the Catholic church guarding. It is said by those who admire them, a truer understanding of Jesus than the Catholic church ever had. And this is why in the 13th century, they were destroyed and extirpated on the orders of the Pope in a terrible crusade, and then targeted by inquisitors over the course of the 13th and 14th century until they vanished. But it is said that the very last of the Cathar fortresses, which was laid siege to by the crusaders, a place called Montségur.
而且他们之所以都很出名，我认为是因为人们觉得他们掌握了一种秘密的智慧。是的。而且在两种情况下，这种智慧都与圣杯有关。是的。所以人们认为圣殿骑士团在守护圣杯，但在其他版本中，则是卡特里派据称在守护——他们的中心在法国南部。也就是朗格多克（Languedoc），
Before it fell, somebody slipped out. And actually, I mean, this is a thesis that goes back long before Dan Brown, long before the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, back to a guy called Josephin Paladin in 1906, who actually set up a secret organization called the Order of the Temple of the Rose and the Cross, in which he cast himself as the Imperator, so the emperor. So kind of very modest. And he argued that what the Cathars had taken when they slipped out from Onsiga was the Holy Grail. Oh, my word. And the Holy Grail in Dan Brown's book.
他们是天主教教会的一个阴暗对立面，守护着——那些崇拜他们的人说——一种比天主教会有史以来掌握的更真实的对耶稣的理解。这就是为什么在 13 世纪，他们在教皇的命令下在一场可怕的十字军东征中被彻底摧毁和消灭，随后在 13 世纪和 14 世纪期间又遭到宗教裁判所的追捕，直到销声匿迹。但据说，卡特里派最后一座遭到十字军围攻的堡垒——
Is Mary Magdalene's bloodline, right? Yes. And also in the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, this book that was written in the 80s by three people, is that right? Well. And they took Dan Brown to court because they said it had obviously been plagiarised and the case got thrown out on the basis
一个名为蒙塞古尔（Montségur）的地方——在它陷落之前，有人悄悄溜了出去。而且，实际上——这个论点远在丹·布朗之前、远在《圣血与圣杯》之前就存在了，可以追溯到 1906 年一个叫约瑟芬·佩拉丹（Josephin Péladan）的人，他甚至建立了一个名为“玫瑰十字圣殿骑士团”（Order of the Temple of the Rose and the Cross）的秘密组织，他在其中自封为“最高统帅”（Imperator），也就是皇帝。真是非常谦逊呢。他辩称，卡特里派从蒙塞古尔溜出来时带走的东西就是圣杯。哦，天哪。而丹·布朗书中的圣杯
that this was now so much part of common understanding. So let's unpack. We'll come to the Cathars because this week we really want to talk about the Cathars and this sort of shadowy conspiracy theory style version of medieval history yeah so who were the who were the cathars what did they believe did they even exist yeah exactly so we should come to that but let's just let's just it's an extraordinary story how you get to dan brown's da vinci code from the cathars and i think it would be really fun to to unpick that because
就是抹大拉的玛丽亚的血脉，对吧？是的。还有在《圣血与圣杯》里——这本书是 80 年代由三个人写的，是这样吗？嗯。他们还把丹·布朗告上了法庭，因为他们说这显然是抄袭，但由于
it's actually a great 20th century story. So The Holy Blood and the Holy Grail was published in 1982 in London. Dan Brown undoubtedly read it and freely admitted. I think it's mentioned in the Da Vinci Code, isn't it? He freely admitted reading it. And Salih Tebe, who is the person in the book, what a brilliant name, who explains the story. His name is an anagram of Michael Bajent, who is one of the authors of The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail.
这些内容现在已经是常识的一部分，所以官司被驳回了。所以我们来剖析一下。我们一会儿会谈到卡特里派，因为本周我们真的想谈谈卡特里派以及这种阴谋论风格的中世纪历史版本。对，那么卡特里派究竟是谁？他们信仰什么？他们真的存在吗？是的，完全如此。所以我们应该谈谈这个，但让我们先捋一捋——从卡特里派演变到丹·布朗的《达芬奇密码》，这是一个非同寻常的故事，我觉得去解构它会非常有趣，因为
So Dan Brown is giving him a little nod there. Now, two of the authors, as you say, sued him for plagiarism. They didn't win the case. They ended up with colossal costs. The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail, they'd written it in 1982, but the book itself was inspired by three programs that had been on the BBC in the 1970s as part of their chronicle strand that had been trying to solve the mystery of a place called Rennes-le-Chateau. So this is a very small village. We'll come to what the mystery is in a second. That's in the heart of Cathar country
这实际上是一个绝佳的 20 世纪故事。《圣血与圣杯》于 1982 年在伦敦出版。丹·布朗毫无疑问读过这本书，并且供认不讳。我想《达芬奇密码》里提到了它，对吧？他大方承认自己读过。而书中的那个解释故事的角色——雷·提宾（Salih Teabing），多棒的名字啊——他的名字其实就是迈克尔·拜根（Michael Baigent）的一个变位字，而迈克尔·拜根正是《圣血与圣杯》的作者之一。
in the southwest of France, down towards the Spanish border in the Languedoc. And the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail has all kinds of different things going on in it. But one of them is this idea of the Priory of Sion, this secret organization that has been protecting the Merovingian bloodline that goes back through Jesus all the way to David from the Old Testament.
所以丹·布朗在那里向他致敬呢。现在，正如你所说，其中两位作者起诉他抄袭。他们没有胜诉，反而背上了巨额的诉讼费。《圣血与圣杯》写于 1982 年，但这本书本身的灵感来自于 1970 年代 BBC“编年史”（Chronicle）节目播出的三集节目，这些节目当时试图解开一个名为雷恩堡（Rennes-le-Chateau）的地方的谜团。这是一个非常小的村庄。我们一会儿再来谈谈这个谜团是什么。它位于法国西南部、
And the argument very explicitly made in the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail by these three writers is that the Catholic Church had been fighting this centuries-long war against the Priory of Sion and the Cathars. So as you said, these characters who are in the long dock in the Middle Ages, that these are one of the most formidable guardians of Mary Magdalene's bloodline. They're, as you said, a sort of shadowy counterpart to the Catholic Church, and they were destroyed on papal orders. But they've kind of lived on in the Priory of Sion.
靠近西班牙边界、朗格多克地区的卡特里派腹地。《圣血与圣杯》包含了各种各样不同的元素。但其中之一就是关于“锡安会”的想法，这个秘密组织一直在保护墨洛温王朝的血脉，而这血脉经由耶稣一直追溯到旧语中的大卫王。
Now, 1982, Britain has only been in the European Union for 10 years. And a lot of people who don't like it think it's a bit weird. And in the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, they say explicitly that the Priory of Sion is devoted to the idea of a United States of Europe, the Holy European Empire. They are planning to install a Merovingian great monarch who will occupy both the papacy, his rightful inheritance, but also the throne of Europe.
这三位作家在《圣血与圣杯》中非常明确地指出，天主教教会一直在对“锡安会”和卡特里派进行长达数个世纪的战争。正如你所说，中世纪朗格多克的这些人物，是抹大拉玛丽亚血脉最强大的守护者之一。正如你所说，他们是天主教教会的一个阴暗对立面，并在教皇的命令下被摧毁了。但他们某种程度上在“锡安会”中延续了下来。
Because if they succeeded in doing that, that could have swung it for Remain, couldn't it? Yes, it could. It could. I mean, this is like Nigel Farage's worst nightmare, because the prior sign of planning a one-party European parliament, Federalist yeah it's run by the merovingians yeah so so this is all there in um but very exciting for early medievalists very well yeah i mean you know you've been toiling away on your charters of late merovingian kings and suddenly suddenly you're in clover yeah your
现在，到了 1982 年，英国加入欧洲共同体才 10 年。许多不喜欢它的人觉得这有点诡异。而在《圣血与圣杯》中，他们明确表示，“锡安会”致力于实现“欧洲合众国”即“神圣欧洲帝国”的理念。他们正计划拥立一位伟大的墨洛温君主，让他既占据教皇宝座（这本就是他的合法继承权），又登上欧洲的王位。
boys have taken over Europe. So that's good news for the early medievalists, and the people presumably standing against them would have been British Eurosceptics of the early 80s. So Tony Benn. Yes. Barbara Castle. Guardians of the Bloodline of Offa. Right.
因为如果他们成功做到这一点，那可能会让“留欧派”大获全胜，对吧？是的，确实会。真的会。我的意思是，这简直是奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）的最噩梦，因为锡安会正计划建立一个单一政党的欧洲议会，搞联邦制——是的，由墨洛温家族来运营。所以——这一切都在书中有所体现。但这对于早期中世纪历史学者来说非常激动人心，嗯，对啊——我的意思是，你最近一直在苦心钻研墨洛温国王的特许状，突然之间，
So, yeah, it's all good stuff. But the thing is that this is based on, as Dan Brown had said in The Da Vinci Code, this is based on documents, on proper, authentic, historical manuscripts from the Bibliotheque Nationale, no less. It doesn't get more historical or authentic than that. It doesn't. Dominic, do you think we should take a break at this point before you reveal what these documents actually said?
你发现自己时来运转了，是吧？你的这群人已经接管了欧洲。所以这对早期中世纪历史学者来说是个好消息，而当时与之对抗的想必就是 80 年代初的英国欧洲怀疑论者了。所以是托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）。是的。芭芭拉·卡斯特（Barbara Castle）。奥法（Offa）血脉的守护者。没错。
Oh, my word. What a cliffhanger. This is full of cliffhangers, this story. Renowned podcaster, Dominic Sandbrook. How old are you? 50? No, I'm 48. A 48-year-old man.
所以，是的，这都是好东西。但问题是，正如丹·布朗在《达芬奇密码》中所说的那样，这一切都是基于文献——来自国家图书馆的、货真价实的真实历史手稿，千真万确。没有什么比这更具历史感和真实感了。确实如此。多米尼克，你觉得在你揭示这些文献究竟写了什么之前，我们是不是应该先休息一下？
A 48-year-old man. We'll now have a break. And when we come back... I hate to say this, but I've just spotted an albino monk trudging up the stairs to all three. So whether I do return, you'll have to find out. You fight him off, and we'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. so whether I do return, you'll have to find out. tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
哦，天哪。真是个悬念迭起的地方。这个故事充满了悬念。著名的播客主持人多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。你多大了？50 岁？不，我 48 岁。一个 48 岁的中年人。
Robert Langdon awoke slowly. A telephone was ringing in the darkness, a tinny, unfamiliar ring. He fumbled for the bedside lamp and turned it on. Squinting at his surroundings, he saw a plush Renaissance bedroom with Louis XVI furniture and frescoed walls, and a colossal mahogany four-poster bed. Where the hell am I? The jacquard bathrobe hanging on his bedpost bore the monogram, Hotel Ritz, Paris. Slowly the fog began to lift. Langdon picked up the receiver. Hello? That was Marcel Proust. I mean, Brad Brown.
一个 48 岁的中年人。我们现在要休息一下。等我们回来——我讨厌这么说，但我刚刚看到一个白化病僧侣正步履蹒跚地爬上通往我们这里的楼梯。所以，我到底能不能回来，你们只能拭目以待了。你去把他打发走，我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。所以，我到底能不能回来，你们只能拭目以待了。想要获取门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
That's Probe. Probe. With another thrilling moment in The Da Vinci Code, which we are discussing. And The Da Vinci Code, Dominic, is a novel in which there is a secret conspiracy to guard the bloodline of christ and before the break you were talking about where this whole strange idea came from and you said that there were some manuscripts that had been found in the bibliothèque nationale in paris and what what are they and where they come from so the the manuscripts amazingly they're called the Dossiers Secrets d'Henri Lobineau, the Secret Dossiers of Henri Lobineau. And they contain part of the history of the Priory of Science,
罗伯特·兰登缓缓醒来。黑暗中响起了电话铃声，那是那种细碎而陌生的铃声。他摸索着打开床头灯。眯起眼睛打量周围，他看到了一间豪华的文艺复兴风格卧室，摆放着路易十六时期的家具，墙上绘有湿壁画，还有一张巨大的桃花心木四柱大床。我究竟在哪儿？挂在床柱上的提花浴袍上绣着交织字母：巴黎丽兹酒店。迷雾开始慢慢散去。兰登拿起听筒。喂？那是马塞尔·普鲁斯特。我是说，布拉德·布朗。
a list of the heads of it and all these sort of documents, correspondence about it and whatnot. So it's very clear that this existed, that the Priory of Science was a real thing because of these documents in the Bibliotheque Nationale. And they were found, Tom. And do these documents have the list of all the, you know? Yes, I think they, I don't know.
那是普鲁布。普鲁布。带我们重温《达芬奇密码》中惊心动魄的时刻，这也是我们正在讨论的话题。而在《达芬奇密码》中，多米尼克，这是一个充满秘密阴谋以守护基督血脉的小说。在休息之前，你谈到了这个奇怪想法的来源，你说在巴黎国家图书馆发现了一些手稿，那到底是什么？它们是从哪儿来的？所以，这些手稿神奇地被称为《亨利·洛比诺秘密档案》（Dossiers Secrets d’Henri Lobineau）。它们包含了部分锡安会的历史，
I think Dan Brown has slightly, and indeed the authors of The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail, have slightly jazzed it up. Have slightly jazzed up those. So Debussy is one of those people. Virginia Woolf. Robert Boyle. Paul McCartney. Exactly.
其历任领袖的名单以及所有这类文件、关于它的通信等等。所以很显然，由于国家图书馆里的这些文件，锡安会是真实存在的，锡安会确实存在过。而且它们被发现了，汤姆。这些文件里有所有那些——你知道的——名单吗？是的，我想它们有，我不知道。
The former lead to United manager, Don Revy. Huge list of people. Anyway, Stanley Baldwin. This list, it was great detective work by one of the authors of The Holy Bird and the Holy Grail. It was a man called Henry Lincoln. And he's really the driving force behind that book because he had done the BBC documentaries in the 70s on the mystery from which the book derives. Now, so who was Henry Lincoln? So we've got a line now connecting Dan Brown,
我觉得丹·布朗稍微——而且《圣血与圣杯》的作者们也是——稍微润色了一下。稍微润色了那些名单。德彪西就是其中之一。弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫。罗伯特·波义耳。保罗·麦卡特尼。没错。
because Dan Brown read this book. Henry Lincoln is a former actor trained at RADA. He was born in 1930, but he's best known, Tom, as a script writer for Doctor Who. Of course he is. So he wrote stories in the Patrick Troughton era of Doctor Who. He wrote a story called The Abominable Snowmen, where they fight Yeti. My uncle was in
前利兹联队主教练唐·雷维（Don Revy）。一大串名单。总之，还有斯坦利·鲍德温。这份名单，是《圣血与圣杯》其中一位作者进行的一项伟大的侦探工作。那个人叫亨利·林肯（Henry Lincoln）。他真的是那本书背后的推动力，因为他在 70 年代制作了基于该谜团的 BBC 纪录片，这本书正是由此演变而来的。那么，亨利·林肯是谁？所以我们现在找到了一条连接丹·布朗的线索，
that. Wow, no way. My beloved uncle, David Gregory, was in that. He was a homicidal Tibetan monk. Yes, it was set in Tibet. The whole theme of homicidal monks. Monks. It's all connecting. Everything connects. Everything connects. Oh, bless him. bless him so he wrote that
因为丹·布朗读过这本书。亨利·林肯是一位曾在 RADA（英国皇家戏剧艺术学院）受训的前演员。他出生于 1930 年，但汤姆，他最著名的身份是《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）的编剧。他当然是了。所以他写过《神秘博士》帕特里克·特劳顿（Patrick Troughton）时期的故事。他写过一个名为《可怕的雪人》（The Abominable Snowmen）的故事，里面他们与雪人搏斗。我叔叔就参演了
he wrote a story called the web of fear where the uh the yeti the abominable snowmen invaded the london underground yes very exciting and he wrote one called the dominators which was useless so we don't know he's a man for plausible plots yeah yes yeah he's a great craftsman anyway in 1969 so actually the end of patrick troughton's time as the second Doctor in Doctor Who, Henry Lincoln is on holiday in the Cévennes, which is in southwestern France. So it's up in the mountains. It's about an hour and a couple of hours drive from Albi, Carcassonne. Right. And so Albi is a great centre.
那集。哇，真的假的。我亲爱的叔叔大卫·格雷戈里（David Gregory）参演了。他演了一个有杀人倾向的西藏僧侣。是的，故事背景设在西藏。有杀人倾向的僧侣这个主题。全都能连起来。万物皆有关联。万物皆有关联。哦，上帝保佑他。上帝保佑他。所以他写了那个，
It's kind of the southernmost bishopric of the southernmost archbishopric in France. Right. So this is the heart of what is called and what is marketed as Cathar country. It's a land. It's quite poor by the standards of France. Very rural. Very mountainous, isn't it? Very mountainous.
他写了一个名为《恐惧之网》（The Web of Fear）的故事，讲的是——雪人、可怕的雪人入侵了伦敦地铁。是的，非常刺激。他还写过一个叫《统治者》（The Dominators）的，不过那集很烂，所以我们就不提了。他是个擅长炮制貌似合理的剧情的人。是的，是的，他是个出色的手艺人。无论如何，在 1969 年——也就是帕特里克·特劳顿作为第二任《神秘博士》主演的任期结束时——亨利·林肯正在法国西南部的塞文山脉（Cévennes）度假。所以那是在山区。从阿尔比（Albi）或卡尔卡松（Carcassonne）开车过去大概要一两个小时。没错。所以阿尔比是一个重要的中心。
Sun bleached. And it's sort of haunted by the ghosts of the Middle Ages, I would say. Ruined castles, ruined churches, a sense that an enormous amount of blood was spilled here once upon a time. And somehow the ghosts are still lingering. And when Henry Lincoln is there, he reads the paperback version of a book that was originally published as Lord of Wren rennes the gold of rennes and this tells him about a mystery in a place called rennes le chateau which is in the heart of the long dock in occitania in the ode department and the story of rennes le chateau is that it had a priest in the 19th century late 19th century called beranger saunière now remember the name of the renowned curator was jacques
它是法国最南端的主教区——最南端的总主教区。没错。所以这里是被称为卡特里派腹地、并以此作为营销卖点的地方的核心。这是一片土地。按法国的标准来看，它相当贫穷。非常乡村化。非常多山，对吧？非常多山。
saunière tom so this is a renowned late 19th century priest well not so renowned it's actually quite obscure okay obscure 19th century priest yes the 76 year old man he was put on ecclesiastical trial in 1909 1910 and he was actually booted out. Why? Why? Well, this book, The Gold of Ren, explained. Saunière had come into an enormous amount of money, or so it seemed, and had spent this money putting esoteric sculptures in his church, mysterious sculptures. And no one could understand where the money came from. And the book that Henry Lincoln was reading in 1969 explained the answer to the mystery. Saunière had found secret documents.
阳光暴晒。我要说的是，这里仿佛被中世纪的幽灵所萦绕。废弃的城堡，废弃的教堂，让人感觉到这里曾经流过大量的血。而那些幽灵不知为何依然徘徊不去。当亨利·林肯在那里时，他读到了一本平装书，这本书最初出版时名为《雷恩的黄金：雷恩堡的秘密》（The Gold of Rennes）。这本书向他讲述了一个位于奥德省（Aude）奥克西塔尼亚（Occitania）朗格多克腹地的雷恩堡（Rennes-le-Château）的一个谜团。雷恩堡的故事是这样的：这里在 19 世纪末有一位神父，名叫贝朗热·索尼埃（Bérenger Saunière）。现在，记住那个著名馆长的名字是雅克·索尼埃（Jacques Saunière），汤姆，所以这是一个著名的 19 世纪末的神父——呃，其实不算著名，其实相当默默无闻。好吧，一个默默无闻的 19 世纪神父。对，那个 76 岁的老人。他在 1909 到 1910 年间受到了教会审判，并实际上被开除了。为什么？为什么？嗯，这本书《雷恩的黄金》解释了原因。索尼埃不知怎么弄到了大笔财富，或者看起来如此，并把这些钱花在给他的教堂建造深奥的雕塑、神秘的雕塑上。没有人能明白这些钱是从哪里来的。而亨利·林肯在 1969 年读的那本书，解释了这个谜团的答案。索尼埃发现了秘密文献。
And so these are the documents in the Bibliothèque Nationale? Either those documents or ones connected to them. And these secret documents proved that Dagobah II, the Merovingian king, had indeed had children, a secret Merovingian bloodline who had been kept hidden all these years and had been guarded by the Cathars, the Templars, and the Priory of Zion. Saunière, Bérenger Saunière, had probably been blackmailing the Catholic Church. The Pope.
那么，这些就是国家图书馆里的文件吗？要么是那些文件，要么是与之相关的文件。而这些秘密文件证明了，墨洛温王朝的国王达戈贝尔特二世确实有后代，这是一个被秘密隐藏了多年的墨洛温血脉，并一直受到卡特里派、圣殿骑士团和锡安会的守护。索尼埃，贝朗热·索尼埃，很可能一直在勒索天主教教会。教皇。
The Pope. That's how he had got all this money to renovate his church. But in which... I mean, I do want to point out the flaw here. Yeah. Well, I do want to point out the flaw. Point it out, Tom. Point it out.
教皇。这就是他如何获得所有这些钱来翻新他的教堂的。但在这一点上——我的意思是，我确实想指出这里的漏洞。嗯，我确实想指出这个漏洞。指出来，汤姆。指出来。
Okay, so if he's blackmailing the Pope. Yeah. Why does the Catholic Church then put him on trial and defrock him? They're running out of money, I expect. It's becoming a very expensive commitment. But how can they do that if he's blackmailing them? He could just say, oh, I'll come out with a secret. Well, he didn't.
好吧，如果他在勒索教皇。对。为什么天主教教会还要审判他并剥夺他的神职呢？我猜他们快没钱了吧。这成了一个非常昂贵的承诺。但如果他在勒索他们，他们怎么能这么做呢？他完全可以大喊：“哦，我要把这个秘密抖出来。”嗯，他没有。
They caught his bluff, I suppose, is how I would interpret it. I'll be honest. I haven't read The Treasure of Wren. I'm not even sure it's still in print. Okay. But The Gold of Wren. So Henry Lincoln reads this book about this priest, and he finds this absolutely fascinating and very plausible.
我猜是他们看穿了他的虚张声势吧，我是这么解释的。老实说，我没读过《雷恩的宝藏》。我甚至不确定它现在是否还在绝版。好吧。但《雷恩的黄金》——所以亨利·林肯读了这本关于这位神父的书，他觉得这绝对引人入胜且非常合情合理。
This is what leads him to the idea of the Priory of Zion. It's what leads him to the documents in the Bibliothèque Nationale. And he then adds the extra element that actually it's not just the Merovingian bloodline that's being guarded, but the Merovingian bloodline is the bloodline of Jesus and Mary Magdalene. So he's the guy who comes up with it. He's the guy, exactly.
这就是他萌生“锡安会”想法的原因。这也是他找到国家图书馆那些文献的原因。然后他又添加了一个额外的元素，即被守护的不仅是墨洛温血脉，而且墨洛温血脉就是耶稣和抹大拉玛丽亚的血脉。所以他才是那个想出这个说法的人？他就是那个人，没错。
He and his fellow authors add that element to it. So now we see that there's another book behind the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, and that book is the Gold of Ren. So who wrote that? So where's this book come from? So this book is written by a man called Gérard de Cèdre. He's from an aristocratic family, born in France in 1921.
他和他的合著者们把这个元素加了进去。所以现在我们看到，《圣血与圣杯》背后还有另一本书，而那本书就是《雷恩的黄金》。那么是谁写的呢？这本书是从哪里来的？这本书是一个叫热拉尔·德·塞德（Gérard de Sède）的人写的。他出身贵族家庭，1921 年出生于法国。
He'd been involved with the Surrealists. But after Surrealism sort of fell from fashion after the Second World War, he just became a bit of a hack. And he was writing tons and tons of books. And the theme of these books that comes up again and again is this thing, the Second World War. He just became a bit of a hack, and he was writing tons and tons of books. And the theme of these books that comes up again and again is this thing, the Cathars again. So, Le Trésor Cathar, Le Secret des Cathars, Le Sang des Cathars, L'Occitanie Rebelle du Moyen-Âge, the Occitania in revolt in the Middle Ages.
他曾与超现实主义者有过交往。但在二战后超现实主义不再流行之后，他沦为了一个平庸的靠文字谋生的写手。他写了海量的书。而这些书中反复出现的一个主题又是——二战。他沦为了一个平庸的写手，写了海量的书。而这些书中反复出现的一个主题又是卡特里派。比如：《卡特里派的宝藏》（Le Trésor Cathar）、《卡特里派的秘密》（Le Secret des Cathars）、《卡特里派之血》（Le Sang des Cathars）、《中世纪叛乱的奥克西塔尼亚》（L'Occitanie Rebelle du Moyen-Âge）。
So, Occitania is south of Medi, like Languedoc. It's the Languedoc. So, Gérard de Sade was obviously obsessed with the Cathars, the middle ages so oxytania is south midi like long dog is the long dog so gerald just said was obviously obsessed with the catholics and this idea that you said that there was this sort of secret occult society group in the south a kind of a shadowy church shadowy church exactly and actually not just in the in the south of france this idea that it it's everywhere but how did he come to to fix on ren ren le chateau how did he come to fix on Ren, Ren Le Chateau? How did he come to write about Sonia? Well, behind him, there is somebody else.
所以，奥克西塔尼亚在米迪南部，就像朗格多克一样。这就是朗格多克。所以热拉尔·德·塞德显然对卡特里派痴迷不已——中世纪嘛，所以奥克西塔尼亚在米迪南部，就像朗格多克一样。所以热拉尔·德·塞德显然对天主教徒——或者说卡特里派痴迷不已，而且坚信你刚才提到的那种在南方存在一个秘密的隐秘社团群体的想法，一个隐秘的教会、阴暗的教会，完全如此。而且事实上，不仅在法国南部，这种想法认为它无处不在。但他究竟是怎么锁定雷恩堡的呢？他是怎么开始写索尼埃的呢？好吧，在他的背后，还有另一个人。
Goodness, it's like Russian dolls. Another, yeah, let's go into the next bit of the Russian doll, the next doll. So this somebody else is the real, so it's taken us half an hour to get to the real protagonist of this episode. And this is an absolutely extraordinary man called Pierre Plantard. And Pierre Plantard was born in 1920.
天哪，这就像俄罗斯套娃一样。又一个，嗯，让我们进入俄罗斯套娃的下一层，下一个玩偶。所以这个“另一个人”才是真正的——所以我们花了半个小时才讲到这一集的真正主角。这是一个绝对非凡的人，名叫皮埃尔·普朗塔（Pierre Plantard），皮埃尔·普朗塔出生于 1920 年。
And his life, it's like a sort of encapsulation of a lot of the themes we've talked about this year in other episodes of The Rest is History. So to start with, we did an episode about servants in the real Downton Abbey with Lucy Lethbridge, Tom. That's our last one. That would last Thursday. And Pierre Ponto is the son of a butler. We talked about butlers in that. He's the son of a butler and a cook. And it's very clear that he was very conscious of being downstairs, the son of downstairs, and he wants to be the son of upstairs. he had a freet on his shoulder he did have a freet on his shoulder yes he is uh he feels very much mr baits when he wants to be the earl of grantham is that right that's the downtown yes very good but then in a nod to another one of them we did a podcast
他的生平就像是对我们今年在《历史其余部分》其他剧集中讨论过的大量主题的一种浓缩。首先，汤姆，我们和露西·莱斯布里奇一起制作了一期关于真实唐顿庄园中仆人的节目。那是我们上一期。那是上周四。皮埃尔·庞塔是管家的儿子，我们在节目中讨论过管家。他是管家和厨师的儿子。很明显，他非常清楚自己身处楼下，是楼下之人的儿子，而他渴望成为楼上之人的儿子。他确实有点愤世嫉俗，是的，他确实有点愤世嫉俗，是的，他感觉自己非常像贝茨先生，当他想成为格兰瑟姆伯爵时，是这样吗？那是唐顿，是的，非常好。但随后，为了呼应我们的另一个播客
series about the rise of the nazis he is one of these interwar teenagers who is drawn into ultra-nationalist organizations so in the late by the late 1930s he has got involved with all kinds of wacky far-right groups in france and actually the comparison there is somebody like himmler because heinrich himmler as we talked about before all that stuff love atlantis vikings yeah pierre plantar the young pierre plantar not only does he want to no longer be the son of a butler, but the son of a Lord. He also is fascinated by all this stuff.
系列——关于纳粹的崛起，他是那种被极端民族主义组织吸引的战间期青少年之一。因此在20世纪30年代末，他参与了法国各种古怪的极右翼组织，事实上，这可以与希姆莱这样的人进行比较，因为正如我们以前讨论过的那样，海因里希·希姆莱对亚特兰蒂斯、维京人等等一切都充满狂热，是的，年轻的皮埃尔·庞塔不仅不想再当管家的儿子，而是想当贵族的儿子。他也对这一切着迷。
When France falls in 1940, he writes to Marshall Pétain and he says, I would like to help out. I would like to help out to fight the Masonic and Jewish conspiracy that has been sapping France's will. You see, he really fancies himself as a knight. I think that's what he really wants to be.
1940年法国沦陷时，他写信给贝当元帅，称自己愿意出一份力。他想出一份力，去打击一直在侵蚀法国意志的共济会和犹太阴谋。你看，他真的把自己想象成一名骑士。我想这才是他真正想成为的人。
He loves the idea of chivalry and of the Templars and of sort of knightly fraternal organizations. And he sets up his own. So he's just a very young man. So like Palladar had set up his organization. Exactly, exactly. He sets up an organization called Alpha Galatees. And he has a magazine.
他热爱骑士精神、圣殿骑士团以及某种骑士兄弟会组织的想法。于是他组建了自己的组织。他当时还只是个年轻人。所以就像帕拉达（Palladar）建立自己的组织一样。没错，没错。他建立了一个名为“阿尔法·加拉蒂斯”（Alpha Galatees）的组织。他还有一本杂志。
The name of the magazine is Vaincre pour une jeune chevalerie. Conquer for a young knighthood, or a knighthood of youth. They have, I think, four members, so not terribly successful. But he's the grandmaster, is he? Yes.
这本杂志的名字叫《为了青年骑士团而征服》（Vaincre pour une jeune chevalerie）。征服为了年轻的骑士团，或者说青春的骑士团。他们好像只有四个成员，所以算不上多么成功。但他是宗师，对吗？是的。
Remember he wanted to fight masonry with Pétain. Pétain didn't take him up on it. So afterward, the war, he becomes a Freemason. He's obviously just fascinated by the idea of societies, secret societies. He also, rather less glamorously, becomes a technical draftsman. That's his day job. But he's always, as time goes on,
还记得他想和贝当一起打击共济会吗？贝当并没有搭理他。所以在战后，他成了一名共济会员。很显然，他只是对各种社团、秘密社团的概念着迷。除此之外，他的另一面则没那么光鲜，他成了一个技术绘图员。那是他的正职。但随着时间的推移，
through all the sort of ructions of post-war France, he's always trying to set things up, to volunteer, to do things. So, for example, when the crisis with the French war in Algeria blows up in 1958, he sets up his own committee of public safety. And he writes to General de Gaulle, doesn't get any reply. It's kind of offering his sword. His sword. To the general. And then he says to people, well, General de Gaulle and I are tremendous any reply. It's kind of offering his sword. His sword. To the general.
在战后法国的各种动荡中，他总是试图建立各种组织，争当志愿者，去做各种事情。例如，1958年阿尔及利亚战争危机爆发时，他成立了自己的公共安全委员会。他写信给戴高乐将军，但没有得到任何回复。这有点像是在向将军献出他的宝剑。他的宝剑。献给将军。然后他对人们说，嗯，戴高乐将军和我非常任何回复。这有点像是在向她的宝剑。献给将军。
And then he says to people, well, General de Gaulle and I are tremendous pals. He's writing to me all the time. Yeah. He also claims to be clairvoyant. So he would have loved the internet. He would. I mean, he'd be all over. He would.
然后他对人们说，嗯，戴高乐将军和我交情莫逆。他一直在给我写信。是的。他还声称自己有先知能力。所以他一定会爱死互联网的。他会的。我的意思是，他会无处不在。他会的。
He'd be. Reddit and all that kind of stuff. He would get on tremendously well with Lawrence Fox, I think it's fair to say. Lawrence Fox would play him. Maybe that's Lawrence Fox's dramatic future. Now, 1956, he set up his own fraternal organization. He's always trying to set up these organizations, not just because he wants to sell knighthoods.
他会泡在Reddit和诸如此类的网站上。我觉得可以说，他会和劳伦斯·福克斯（Lawrence Fox）相处得极其融洽。劳伦斯·福克斯会在剧中扮演他。也许这就是劳伦斯·福克斯未来的演艺道路。1956年，他建立了属于自己的兄弟会组织。他总是试图建立这些组织，不仅仅是因为他想出卖骑士头衔。
He's like David Lloyd George. He wants to sell peerages and honors. David Lloyd George is prime minister, so he can kind of do that. Pierre Prontar is not. He's a technical craftsman. And do you know what his fraternal organization is called? The Priory of Sion? The Priory of Sion.
他就像大卫·劳埃德·乔治。他想出卖贵族爵位和荣誉。大卫·劳埃德·乔治是首相，所以他某种程度上能做到这一点。皮埃尔·庞塔可不是。他只是个技术工匠。你知道他的兄弟会组织叫什么名字吗？锡安修道院？锡安修道院。
This, contra what Dan Brown claims, this is where the Priory of Sion originated. He set it up in the town of Animas in Haute-Savoie. So that's in the east of France. It was called Sion because there was a hill outside the town called Scion,
与丹·布朗的说法相反，这就是锡安修道院的起源地。他在上萨瓦省的阿马纳镇建立的。那是在法国东部。它之所以被称为锡安（Sion），是因为镇外有一座名为希翁（Scion）的小山，
and he was planning to build a New Age retreat on this hill. So that's why he – it's a money-making venture, Tom. Now, the statutes of the Priory of Scion, all organizations had to be registered with the French government. So we know what the statutes were. The statutes said, and it does sound impressive, its mission was to carry out good deeds, to help the Roman Catholic Church, to teach the truth,
他正计划在那座山上建立一个新时代静修所。所以这就是他——这是一笔赚钱的生意，汤姆。现在，锡安修道院的章程，所有组织都必须在法国政府注册。所以我们知道章程写的是什么。章程规定——听起来确实令人印象深刻——其使命是行善事、协助罗马天主教会、宣扬真理，
and to defend the weak and the oppressed. So that sounds splendid. But we also know from its records what it actually did. And its involvement seems to have been two things. One, it was trying to run the school buses of their local town, trying to get a contract to run the school buses.
并捍卫弱者和被压迫者。这听起来很崇高。但从其记录中，我们也知道它实际做过什么。它的参与似乎主要有两件事。第一，它试图运营当地镇上的校车，争取承包校车业务。
And the other, there was a huge sort of NIMBY-ish controversy about the building of social housing in Animas, and Plantard got involved with that. So he's sort of corresponding about that and having meetings. So this is very much not guarding bloodlines of Christ, is it? There was no guarding of any bloodlines. No, at this stage, they were arguing about flats and planning permission and residents' complaints. I guess anyone who's been involved in that kind of thing would accept that introducing a bloodline of Christ would spice the correspondence up.
第二，在阿马纳建设社会住房的问题上引发了大规模的“邻避效应”争议，庞塔也卷入了其中。所以他一直在就此进行通信并开会。这跟守护基督血脉可以说毫无关系，对吧？根本没有什么血脉守护。不，在这个阶段，他们争论的都是公寓、规划许可和居民投诉。我猜，任何经历过那种事情的人都会承认，引入基督的血脉会让这些信件变得更有滋有味。
Well, this is exactly what happens. So it's very clear that in the early 1960s, so at this point he is in his mid-40s and it hasn't worked out. So he decides he's going to turbocharge it. And I admire him in some ways. He's very entrepreneurial. He decides to do things. First of all, he reboots theots the prior sign as this sort of
嗯，这正是接下来发生的事情。很显然，在20世纪60年代初，当时他已经四十多岁了，事情并没有按预期发展。于是他决定给它加码。在某些方面我还挺佩服他的。他极具创业精神。他决定采取行动。首先，他将锡安修道院重启为一种
esoteric chivalric fellowship and he wants to he thinks he can make more money out of it this way he can basically sell membership if he really bigs up what it's all about it's not just about being kind anymore yeah it's kind of like selling tartan in scotland to american tourists that kind of i guess so yes yes exactly he says um nostradamus predicted the the arrival of a great monarch who will take the throne of france this is what we're all about and we actually know you know when we know loads of secrets about this and who is the great monarch well might it be him unbelievably it's actually himself well who knew um so he says he he creates this sort of pedigree for the priory of zion and he says um
秘契骑士团，他认为通过这种方式他可以赚到更多的钱。如果他把这一切吹得足够宏大，他基本上就可以出售会员资格了。这不再仅仅是关于善良了，是的，这有点像在苏格兰向美国游客兜售格子呢，那种感觉我猜是的，是的，完全如此。他说，嗯，诺查丹玛斯预言了一位将登上法国王座的伟大君主的到来，这就是我们存在的意义，实际上我们知道，你知道吗，我们对此掌握了大量的秘密，而这位伟大的君主是谁呢？难以置信，其实就是他自己。好吧，谁能想到呢，嗯。所以他说，他为锡安修道院制造了这样一种血统，并说，
it's actually you know we're actually descended from a secret catholic order um founded in the kingdom of jerusalem in 1099 in the first crusade so this is the that's where dan brown gets gets gets 1099 yeah but pierre pountar is not a fool i mean he he might be a conspiracy theorist but but he's not a fool. He knows that this is all very spurious, and there's no evidence for any of his claims. So what he does that is absolutely brilliant is he just creates the evidence. So he and his mate start working up in their spare time documents,
事实上，你知道，我们实际上是源自一个秘密的天主教修会，该修会于1099年第一次十字军东征期间在耶路撒冷王国成立。这就是丹·布朗1099年说法的来源，是的。但皮埃尔·庞塔并不傻。我的意思是，他可能是一个阴谋论者，但他并不傻。他知道这一切都是虚假的，而且没有任何证据支持他的任何说法。因此，他做了一件绝对绝妙的事——他自己制造了证据。于是他和他的朋友在业余时间开始炮制文件、
manuscripts, which they call the Dossierrets d'Henri Lobineau, the Secret Files of Henri Lobineau, the Degeneres and Merovingian Kings, their lists of the heads of the Priory of Sion. They go to the Bibliothèque Nationale in Paris, and they order files up, and they just sort of stuff these documents. And of course,
手稿，他们称之为“亨利·洛比诺档案”（Dossiers d'Henri Lobineau）、亨利·洛比诺的秘密档案、日耳曼和墨洛温王朝国王档案、锡安修道院历任领袖名单。他们前往巴黎的法国国家图书馆，调阅档案，然后把这些文件塞进去。当然，
you can completely see anyone who's been to an archive can see how that would work. It's quite hard to maybe to steal documents. But easier. But far easier to put them in. Have they written them on kind of faded parchment? Exactly. They're probably putting bits of tea on it and stuff, all that stuff. So not only do they do that, he also gets in touch with that bloke,
你去过档案室的话，完全能想象这具体是怎么运作的。偷走文件可能有点困难。但更容易。但把东西塞进去要容易得多。他们是用那种褪色的羊皮纸写的吗？完全正确。他们可能在上面抹了茶水之类的东西，全套戏码。他们不仅这么做，他还联系了那个家伙，
Gerard de Ceyde, and says, I think you should write a book called The Gold of Rennes and link this to this mystery of Rennes de Chateau, the Merovingian bloodline. So here's the extraordinary thing. Henry Lincoln read the book that Pierre Pontard had commissioned and then, of his own back, went and did the detective work in the Bibliothèque Nationale. And discovered the documents. And discovered the documents that Pierre Pantard had also... What shocks Pierre Pantard, though, is that Henry Lincoln brings in the stuff about Jesus and Mary Magdalene, because that was not in his initial plan.
热拉尔·德·塞德（Gerard de Sede），说：“我觉得你应该写一本名为《雷恩的黄金》的书，并把这与雷恩堡（Rennes-le-Chateau）的神秘事件、墨洛温王朝的血脉联系起来。”接下来的事情非同寻常。亨利·林肯（Henry Lincoln）读了皮埃尔·庞塔委托创作的那本书，然后自发前往法国国家图书馆进行侦探般的调查。并发现了这些文件。并发现了皮埃尔·庞塔也……然而让皮埃尔·庞塔震惊的是，亨利·林肯引入了关于耶稣和抹大拉的玛丽亚的内容，因为这并不在他的最初计划之内。
And when The Holy Bird and the Holy Grail came out in 1982, Pierre Pantard said, what's all this? This stuff about Jesus is nonsense. And so the idea that Europe in the 80s would come to be ruled by a Merovingian, that Pierre Plantard is offering himself
当《圣血与圣杯》于1982年出版时，皮埃尔·庞塔说：“这都是些什么？关于耶稣的这些内容简直是一派胡言。”因此，80年代的欧洲将由一个墨洛温王朝后裔统治的想法，其实是皮埃尔·庞塔将自己
as his king. But when we say he's offering himself, he thought he'd perhaps make £10,000 a year out of selling to gullible dupes selling knighthoods or books or whatever. But in the end he wasn't
塑造成了国王。但当我们说他把自己塑造成国王时，他原本以为通过向容易受骗的傻子出售骑士头衔、书籍或其他东西，每年大概能赚到1万英镑。但最终，赚钱的并不是
the one making the money. No. It was Henry Lincoln and Dan Brown Right, versions was that. But why has he made that link to Wren? There's a story behind the story behind the story Tom. Of course. So Wren Le Chateau as we said is in Cathar country, there's a, there's a story behind the story behind the story, Tom. Of course. So Ren, the Chateau is in,
他。不。是亨利·林肯和丹·布朗。没错，情况就是这样。但为什么他会和雷恩建立这种联系？这个故事背后还有一个故事的故事，汤姆。当然。所以雷恩堡，正如我们所说，位于卡特尔派地区，这里有一个，故事背后还有一个故事的故事，汤姆。当然。所以雷恩堡位于，
as we said, was in, is in Cathar country. It's in the far Southwest of, um, France. And would you believe Pierre Pontard got the idea because he had read yet another book. And this was a book about treasure hunting.
正如我们所说，过去是，现在是卡特尔派地区。它位于法国的极西南部，呃。你敢信，皮埃尔·庞塔之所以有这个想法，是因为他读了另一本书。这是一本关于寻宝的书。
Um, the book was called Tresor du Monde. It was about where, where there's buried treasure. And this book was published in the early 60s and it told the story of a man called Noël Corbu. So yet another bizarre character to add to our story. Noël Corbu is a bit older than all the others. He was born in 1912. He'd been brought up in Morocco. He'd ended up running a pasta factory in Perpignan.
这本书名叫《世界宝藏》（Tresor du Monde）。讲的是埋藏的宝藏在哪里。这本书出版于20世纪60年代初，讲述了一个名叫诺埃尔·科尔比（Noël Corbu）的人的故事。又是一个可以加入我们故事的古怪角色。诺埃尔·科尔比比其他人都要年长一些。他出生于1912年。他在摩洛哥长大。后来在佩皮尼昂经营一家面食工厂。
And then he went back to Morocco to try to open a sugar refinery in the 50s. This was a very bad time to be a Frenchman opening sugar refineries in North Africa because Algeria had exploded. North Africa is trying to throw off French overlordship. Noel Corbu comes back to France with his tail between his legs to sort of start again. At about that point in the 50s, he sees for sale a hotel and restaurant in this, you know, obscure kind of fly-blown, windswept, long-dock town called Rennes-le-Château. And it's on sale,
然后在50年代，他又回到摩洛哥试图开设一家糖厂。在北非当法国人开糖厂可不是个好时候，因为阿尔及利亚爆发了革命。北非正试图摆脱法国的统治。诺埃尔·科尔比夹着尾巴回到法国，准备重新开始。大约在50年代的那个时候，他在这个名不见经传、饱受风吹日晒、死气沉沉的朗格多克小镇雷恩堡看中了一家待售的酒店和餐厅。它正在出售，
and the person who's trying to get rid of it is a woman called Marie Desnardneau. Marie Desnardneau. And she is the former housekeeper trying to get rid of it is a woman called Marie Denano Marie Denano and she is the former housekeeper of Beranger Sonnier the priest the controversial mysterious priest Noël Corbeau
而试图脱手它的人是一位名叫玛丽·德纳尔诺（Marie Denardneau）的女士。玛丽·德纳尔诺。她曾是试图脱手它的人是一位名叫玛丽·德纳尔诺的女士。玛丽·德纳尔诺。她曾是贝朗热·索尼埃（Beranger Sonnier）的管家，那个充满争议、神秘的神父。诺埃尔·科尔比
buys her house and runs it as this hotel and restaurant if you've ever been to the Languedoc, have you been to the Languedoc Tom? Not only have I been to the Languedoc I've been to ren le chateau then you will know that it's a long way from paris i made my parents go did you oh my word the whole way wow where from where were you staying can't remember it's near toulouse okay so not staying outside toulouse but still if you go to the cathar castle so ren le chateau is very close to castles like what's it called Père Pétus
买下了她的房子，并将其作为酒店和餐厅经营。如果你去过朗格多克，汤姆，你去过朗格多克吗？我不仅去过朗格多克，我还去过雷恩堡。那你就会知道，那离巴黎可真够远的。我让我父母陪我去的，真的吗？天哪，一路过去！哇，从哪里出发的？你在哪里落脚的？记不清了，在图卢兹附近。好吧，所以不是住在图卢兹外面，但即便如此，如果你去看卡特尔派城堡，雷恩堡非常靠近那些城堡，比如那个叫什么来着的，佩特斯
Keribus these amazing I mean some of the best castles you'll ever see these ruined castles on mountains the romance of them is that they are
克里比斯（Keribus），这些太棒了，我的意思是，这是你能见到的最好的城堡，这些矗立在山上的废墟城堡，它们的浪漫之处在于，它们是
their last strongholds of the Cathars yeah and so the Montségur which is the most famous of the lot yeah captured in 1244
卡特尔派最后的据点，对吧。还有蒙塞居尔（Montségur），这是其中最著名的，对吧，在1244年被攻陷。
it's the kind of the Masada the last outpost of the Cathars. And that story of the Holy Grail being taken down, another version of it is that the Cathars are removing their treasure. Ah, right. Well, we'll come to treasure.
它有点像马萨达，是卡特尔派最后的哨所。关于圣杯被运走的那个传说，另一种说法是卡特尔派在转移他们的宝藏。啊，原来如此。好吧，我们会谈到宝藏的。
So the treasure could be the Holy Grail. Yes. Or it could be, you know, I don't know, the treasure of the Cathars or something. Well, we've got some treasure coming up in a second. But the point is, if you've been to these castles, I mean, we went a few years ago, they're surprisingly untouristed because although they're magnificent,
所以宝藏可能是圣杯。是的。或者也可能是，我不知道，卡特尔派的宝藏什么的。好吧，我们马上就会讲到一些宝藏。但关键是，如果你去过这些城堡——我的意思是，我们几年前去过——它们出奇地没有什么游客，因为尽管它们很雄伟，
they're a long way from anywhere. It's very hard to get to them, winding roads, mountain roads, and so on. So, Noel Corbu has this hotel and restaurant, and he's desperate to drum up custom. How on earth is he going to get people there? He makes two claims to the local press. The first claim that he makes in La Depeche du Midi in 1956, he says, that bloke Bérenger Saunière, I know where he got his money. He found treasure in his church.
但它们离任何地方都很远。很难到达那里，盘山路、山路等等。所以，诺埃尔·科尔比开了这家酒店和餐厅，他迫切想要招揽顾客。他到底要怎么把人吸引过去呢？他向当地媒体提出了两个说法。他在1956年的《南方快报》（La Depeche du Midi）上发表了第一个说法，他说：“那个叫贝朗热·索尼埃的家伙，我知道他的钱是从哪来的。他在自己的教堂里发现了宝藏。”
And the treasure was the treasure of Blanche of Castile, this daughter of the Spanish, the Castilian king, married the French king. She had assembled 28 million gold pieces to pay the ransom of Saint Louis, the French crusader king who had been taken prisoner by the Saracens. And the treasure was buried. Béonger Saunière found half, and half is still there.
这个宝藏就是卡斯蒂利亚的布兰雪（Blanche of Castile）的宝藏。这位西班牙卡斯蒂利亚国王的女儿嫁给了法国国王。她筹集了2800万金币，用来支付十字军东征的法国国王圣路易斯的赎金，圣路易斯当时被萨拉森人俘虏了。而宝藏就被埋在那里。贝朗热·索尼埃找到了其中一半，另一半还在那儿。
Brilliant. Brings in treasure hunters to his restaurant. Superb. So that's superb. So basically this whole thing is about restaurants. Custom. No, but about people trying to make money. Of course.
太绝了。这把寻宝者都吸引到他的餐厅去了。太棒了。这真是太棒了。所以基本上这一切都是为了餐馆。招揽顾客。不，但这都是关于人们如何想方设法赚钱。当然。
With various scams. And his second element, which is about hidden manuscripts, he says he's done the treasure, and then he says, actually, you know what, Saunière didn't just find the treasure. It's one of those conspiracy theorists who has multiple elements. He says he also found parchments, manuscripts. And do you know what they were? They were Gnostic gospels.
各种骗局。至于他的第二个元素——关于隐藏的手稿，他说完宝藏的事后，又说：“实际上，你知道吗，索尼埃不仅找到了宝藏。”这就是那种具有多重元素的阴谋论者。他说他还找到了羊皮纸和手稿。你猜它们是什么？它们是诺斯替福音书（Gnostic gospels）。
And why on earth has he picked on this of all things? The answer is obvious. It's the mid-1950s, and the French press is full of the Dead Sea Scrolls, which are even at this point being found and being transcribed and whatnot. So it obviously makes... It's in the air. It's in the air. Now, he eventually sold the hotel and bought a little sort of chateau.
他为什么偏偏挑中这个？答案显而易见。那是20世纪50年代中期，法国各大媒体到处都在报道《死海古卷》，当时《死海古卷》正被发掘、翻译等等。所以这显然让……这成了当时的社会热点。这成了热点。后来他把酒店卖了，买了一个小城堡。
So he must have made a decent amount of money from this sort of scheme. Pure money-making scheme to bring in people to eat steak frites at his restaurants. Noel Corby was killed in a car accident in 1968. And of course, when somebody's killed in a car accident in these kinds of stories, everyone says- Yeah, conspiracy. Opus Dei. That's the Catholic Church acting.
所以他一定通过这种骗局赚了一大笔钱。纯粹是为了把人吸引到他的餐厅去吃牛排薯条而设计的赚钱骗局。诺埃尔·科尔比于1968年在一次车祸中丧生。当然，在这类故事中，当有人在车祸中丧生时，每个人都会说——是的，阴谋。主业会（Opus Dei）。那是天主教会下的手。
Or possibly the Priory of Zion. Possibly, yes. Who knows? Because he's spilling their secrets. It's very hard to tell, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, who knows? Listeners will have their own views so but their counsel in ren le chateau even though they're a tiny bit dubious they've
或者可能是锡安修道院。也许吧，谁知道呢？因为他泄露了他们的秘密。这很难说，对吧？是的。我的意思是，谁知道呢？听众们会有自己的看法，但雷恩堡的当地人，尽管他们有点可疑，
encouraged these theories ever since well they would i mean the whole the whole have you been um i've not been to the town i've been the village of ren le chateau is absolute mecca for all of this yeah i mean it's kind of heaving with crystals and yeah of course on the templars and the catholic well of course if you go to this area everywhere you go i mean the branding is you know it's catholic country catholic castles sites of massacres sieges mysterious churches all of this kind of stuff but to go back to the very beginning of the actual conspiracy theory, this priest, Bérenger Saunière, he was a priest in Rennes-le-Château between 1885 and 1909. He was, you know, tending to his flock in this landscape of castles and ghosts and whatnot. He does spend a lot of money renovating his church with mysterious sculptures.
但他们从那以后一直在鼓励这些理论。好吧，他们当然会这么做——整件事、整个……你去过吗？我没去过那个小镇，我去过雷恩堡村，这里简直是所有这些传说的朝圣地，对吧？我的意思是，这里到处都是水晶，当然还有关于圣母、圣殿骑士团和天主教的……当然，如果你去这个地区，无论走到哪里——我的意思是，这里的品牌营销就是，这里是天主教国家、天主教城堡、大屠杀遗址、围城战发生地、神秘的教堂，所有这些。但回到实际阴谋论的最开始，这个神父贝朗热·索尼埃，他在1885年至1909年间是雷恩堡的神父。他一直在城堡、幽灵等背景下照顾他的信徒。他的确花了很多钱用神秘的雕塑翻新他的教堂。
However, the sculptures, people have traced where they came from they all came from a catalog from a kind of job lot weren't they job lot yeah she's carved to lose who was a local sort of sculpture quite sculpted quite well known at the time there's nothing esoteric about them but i'll show you just literally pick them out of the catalog devils i'll have a bit of going to the garden center exactly just like going to the garden so they look very much like garden centre gnomes, I think some of them. And the money, it wasn't treasure.
然而，这些雕塑，人们已经追溯了它们的来源，它们全部来自一个批量货品目录，对吧？批量货品目录，是的。由一个当地颇有名气的雕刻师在卡尔卡松雕刻的，当时很有名。它们没有什么神秘色彩，但我向你展示一下，就是直接从目录里挑出来的恶魔。我去一趟园艺中心。完全就像去园艺中心一样，所以它们看起来非常像园艺中心的侏儒，我觉得其中有些确实如此。至于钱，那根本不是宝藏。
It wasn't blackmailing the papacy. He was selling masses. And that's why he gets kicked out. Defrocked. Defrocked, exactly. What he actually had done, he got hold of a directory of French clergymen and ecclesiastical organisations.
那不是勒索教廷。他是在兜售弥撒。这就是他被赶出门的原因。被剥夺神职。被剥夺神职，完全正确。他实际做的是，他弄到了一份法国神职人员和教会组织的通讯录。
He just wrote to them all the time saying, do you want me to say a mass for you? Do you got any masses you want doing? And he was actually taking money for masses that he had. He didn't, he got so many requests. He didn't have time, but had money,
他一直给他们写信，问：“你想让我为你做一场弥撒吗？你有什么需要做的弥撒吗？”他实际上是在为他已经接下的弥撒收取费用。他没有——他收到的请求太多了。他根本忙不过来，但他收到了钱，
which he, which to his credit, he spent on the church, but the church booted him out. So, so that's where it all started. Now, if we stop for a second,
说实话，他把这些钱花在了教堂上，但教堂把他给踢出去了。所以，一切就是从这里开始的。现在，如果我们停顿一下，
turn the story around, tell it the other way. So let's now, instead of moving backwards, go forwards. So you had a priest in Cathar country in the southwest of France who was flogging all these masses, got this money. The restaurateur exaggerates his story and makes up some stuff about treasure and parchments so that he'll bring custom to his restaurants. Pierre Pontard, the butler's son who wants to be the lord, he's inspired by this to develop all these parchments about his Merovingian lineage,
把故事反过来讲，从另一个方向说。所以现在我们不往回看，而是往前看。在法国西南部的卡特尔派地区有一个神父，他一直在兜售弥撒，赚到了这笔钱。餐馆老板夸大了他的故事，编造了一些关于宝藏和羊皮纸的故事，好把顾客吸引到他的餐厅。皮埃尔·庞塔——那个想当贵族的管家儿子，受此启发，炮制了所有关于自己墨洛温王朝血统的羊皮纸，
which he deposits in the Bibliothèque Nationale, and he commissions a hack writer who's fascinated by the Cathars, called Gerard de Cèdre, to write a book about the parchments. Henry Lincoln from Doctor Who reads this book on holiday. In Cathar country. In Cathar country. he writes the holy blood and the holy grail and he adds an extra element that has never been in the story for this point which is also from the history of the cathars because it is claimed that the cathars believed it that jesus and mary magdalene had been a couple and had had children. And old boy of Phillips Exeter Academy and champion fawn polo shirt wearer, Dan Brown,
并将它们存放在法国国家图书馆，他还委托了一个迷恋卡特尔派的雇佣文人热拉尔·德·塞德（Gerard de Cèdre）写一本关于这些羊皮纸的书。来自《神秘博士》的亨利·林肯在度假时读到了这本书。在卡特尔派地区。在卡特尔派地区。他写了《圣血与圣杯》，并在故事中加入了一个此前从未有过的元素，这也是从卡特尔派的历史中借鉴来的，因为据称卡特尔派相信耶稣和抹大拉的玛丽亚曾是一对夫妻并育有子女。而菲利普埃克塞特学院的毕业生、钟爱鹿牌马球衫的资深人士丹·布朗，
master of prose, reads the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail and writes his own version, bringing all these elements. And when interviewed is asked if it is true. And he says, absolutely all of it and of course the thing is tom none of this would have lodged in people's minds if they didn't already have a sense that in that part of the world there has been something strange going on something occult and esoteric and hidden and dark and dangerous. And that, of course, is the story of the Cathars that underpins all this. Yes. And I think what is fascinating, so it's fascinating as a story about how myths have evolved over the course of the 20th century. I mean, it's kind of brilliant exemplification of that.
这位散文大师，读了《圣血与圣杯》，并写出了他自己的版本，将所有这些元素融为一体。当接受采访被问及这是否属实时。他说，绝对全都是真的。当然，问题在于，汤姆，如果人们本来就没有感觉到那个世界的一部分一直发生着某种奇怪、神秘、隐秘、黑暗而危险的事情，所有这些根本不会留在人们的脑海中。而这，当然就是支撑这一切的卡特尔派的故事。是的。而且我认为迷人之处在于，作为一个关于神话在20世纪演变过程的故事，它极其迷人。我的意思是，它是这方面一个绝佳的例证。
But I think it is also interesting for the fact that it is drawing on something that is mysterious about the Middle Ages. And the way that the Cathars have been understood does hold a mirror up to all kinds of conspiracies and accusations and mysteries that were absolutely authentic within the Middle Ages. So the question is, what is the relationship of the contemporary understanding of the Cathars to what was actually going on in, let's call it, the Languedoc, the Cathar country in the Middle Ages? And I mean, I think it's important to recognize that the Cathars in contemporary culture are not, they're kind of integrated into this idea of a conspiracy of the bloodline of Christ. I mean, that's probably what they're best known for. But there is also a kind of new age vibe. So that's why when you go to Renla Chateau, you have all the crystals and everything. And I guess that there is another
但我认为它也很有趣，因为它借鉴了中世纪某些神秘的东西。人们理解卡特尔派的方式，确实为中世纪那些绝对真实的阴谋、指控和神秘事件提供了一面镜子。所以问题是，当代对卡特尔派的理解与中世纪——我们称之为朗格多克或卡特尔派地区——实际发生的事情之间是什么关系？我认为重要的是要认识到，当代文化中的卡特尔派并非如此，他们被某种程度上整合进了基督血脉阴谋的概念中。我的意思是，这可能是他们最广为人知的方面。但这里也有一种新时代（New Age）的氛围。所以这就是为什么当你去雷恩堡时，到处都是水晶等等。我想还有另一本
hugely bestselling novel that features the Cathars, which gives it a feminist spin, which was Kate Moss's novel Labyrinth, which came out in 2006. And so she was writing it as Dan Brown was writing The Da Vinci Code. And as in The Da Vinci Code, the Cathars are, in Kate Moss's novel, they're guarding an ancient wisdom. They're hated by the Catholics for being a rival church. They're dualists who believe that God is the God of heaven, the devil is the God of the earth. And the Cathars in Kate Moss's version of it are very feminist. Women can become priests. And this is all part of the reason why the evil Catholic Church orders it to be destroyed. I mean, the question that we will be going on from over the next few episodes, look at what the reality of this, but what is fascinating about this, that in the 70s, 80s, 90s, into the 21st century, when all these novels and these books with the idea of the Cathars as guardians of kind of secret wisdom coming out, this is basically, it's a popularization of the standard history that you will find in academic studies and histories of the period. And these are histories that are coming out at the same time in the 70s, 80s, 90s into the 21st century.
大受欢迎、以卡特尔派为主角并赋予其女性主义色彩的小说，那就是凯特·莫斯（Kate Moss）2006年出版的小说《迷宫》（Labyrinth）。所以当丹·布朗在写《达·芬奇密码》时，她也在写这本书。正如在《达·芬奇密码》中一样，在凯特·莫斯的小说中，卡特尔派守护着古老的智慧。他们因为是一个对立教会而遭到天主教徒的痛恨。他们是二元论者，相信上帝是天堂之神，魔鬼是尘世之神。在凯特·莫斯版本的小说中，卡特尔派非常具有女性主义色彩。女性可以成为神父。而这正是邪恶的天主教教会下令将其消灭的部分原因。我的意思是，我们在接下来的几集节目中将继续探讨的，正是这些现象背后的现实是什么。但最吸引人的是，在20世纪70、80、90年代直至21世纪，当所有这些将卡特尔派视为某种秘密智慧守护者的小说和书籍涌现时，这基本上就是对你在学术研究和该时期历史中能够找到的标准历史的一种通俗化。而这些历史正是在同一时期——70、80、90年代直至21世纪——不断涌现出来的。
And in these books, and they will have titles like, you know, History of the Cathars. Yeah. Cathars feature in these titles, and they are described by academics, by historians as having been the most formidably organized of all medieval heretics, that effectively they are what the Catholics claim they were, that they were a kind of shadowy
在这些书中，它们的书名通常是《卡特尔派史》之类的主题。是的。卡特尔派在这些书名中占据显著地位，并被学者和历史学家描述为中世纪所有异端中最具组织力的一群人，他们实际上就是天主教徒所声称的那样——一个带有主教、结构、教区和各种事物的隐秘
counter church with bishops, with structures, with parishes, all kinds of things. They are dualist, as Kate Moss implies in her novel Labyrinth, that there's an active malign devil on the earth, there's a good God in heaven, that matter is evil, that spirit is good. There were elements within the Cathars who did think that Jesus and Mary had married. That these traditions that you get in, so you mentioned about the Gnostic Gospels and also about the Dead Sea Scrolls, academics argue that these traditions that are found in the medieval Languedoc, they're continuous, that they're living, that they go all they date back to the age of the Gnostic Gospels, to the time before
反主流教会。正如凯特·莫斯在小说《迷宫》中所暗示的那样，他们是二元论者，认为尘世有一个积极作恶的魔鬼，天堂有一个善意的上帝，物质是邪恶的，精神是善良的。卡特尔派内部确实有部分人认为耶稣和玛丽亚结过婚。正如你提到的诺斯替福音书以及《死海古卷》一样，学者们认为，在中世纪朗格多克发现的这些传统具有连续性、生命力，它们可以追溯到诺斯替福音书的时代，追溯到
Constantine, then immediately afterwards, that this tradition arrives in the West from the Byzantine Empire, where these traditions have long, long been underground, that they have come via missionaries from Bulgaria, who are called Bogomils, the Bogomils, who hold these heretical beliefs, that they arrive, that missionaries from Bogomil missionaries arrive in the south of France, and that they set up the Cathar church there, but that the Cathars of L'Encadoc are part of a wider and organized European movement. And all of this you will find in academic studies that are being written at exactly the same time as the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail are being written, and the Denshi code and labyrinth and the history of this is very tragic because by the early 13th century the catholic church understandably is getting alarmed by the you know the discovery that there is this shadowy church
君士坦丁之前的时代以及随后的时期，这一传统从拜占庭帝国传入西方，这些传统在拜占庭长期隐秘流传，它们是通过来自保加利亚的被称为鲍格米利派（Bogomils）的传教士传入的，鲍格米利派持有这些异端信仰，鲍格米利传教士抵达法国南部，并在那里建立了卡特尔派教会，但朗格多克的卡特尔派是更广泛、更有组织的欧洲运动的一部分。所有这一切，你都可以在与《圣血与圣杯》、《达·芬奇密码》以及《迷宫》几乎同时撰写的学术研究中找到，而这段历史非常悲惨，因为到13世纪初，天主教教会理所当然地开始对发现身边存在这样一个隐秘教会感到惊恐，
on their doorstep i mean not in their doorstep kind of you know right in the middle of of france the most the most catholic kingdom and so they launch a crusade. And this is the first crusade that is launched not against Saracens, not against infidels, but against supposed Christians, people within the fabric of Western Christendom. And it's incredibly bloody and brutal. It lasts for 20 years. In its wake, there is a kind of continuous program of extirpation, which involves both military campaigns. In Mosegur is the kind of continuous program of extirpation which involves both military campaigns in mosiger is the last of these military campaigns but also inquisitors moving in yeah and this lasts right the way into the 14th century some people have called it a genocide haven't
我的意思是，不在他们身边，而是在法国正中央——这个最天主教的王国——的腹地，于是他们发动了一场十字军东征。这是第一次针对的不是萨拉森人、不是异教徒，而是所谓的基督徒、西方基督教世界内部成员的十字军东征。它极其血腥和残酷，持续了20年之久。随之而来的是一种持续的根除计划，其中包括军事行动。蒙塞居尔就是这种持续根除计划的最后一场军事行动，此外还有不断深入的审讯官，是的，这种情况一直持续到14世纪。有些人称之为大屠杀，不是吗？
they i mean they've people have called it a genocide and that by the mid 14th century the cathar church is is pretty much wiped out it vanishes, but that there are shadowy traces of it that kind of reemerge periodically. So in kind of Protestant sects and so on. So that is what scholars until about 15, 20 years ago were pretty much unanimously arguing. However, I want to end this episode by quoting a line from a book called A Most Holy War, The Albigensian Crusade and the Battle for Christendom by a scholar called Mark Gregory Pegg. It's a fantastic book, absolutely thrilling work of history. It's fabulously well written. I mean, very, very kind of exciting. Is it as well written as the Da Vinci Code?
我的意思是，人们称之为大屠杀，到14世纪中期，卡特尔派教会基本上被彻底摧毁并消失了，但它的隐秘痕迹会周期性地重新浮现。比如在某种新教教派等等之中。这就是大约15、20年前学者们几乎一致的观点。然而，我想在这集节目的结尾引用一本书中的一句话，这本书名叫《一场最神圣的战争：阿尔比十字军东征与争夺基督教世界的战斗》，作者是一位名叫马克·格雷戈里·佩格（Mark Gregory Pegg）的学者。这是一本非常棒的书，是一部绝对惊心动魄的历史著作，文笔极其优美。我的意思是，非常非常引人入胜。它有《达·芬奇密码》写得那么好吗？
That's the question. It certainly rivals the Da da vinci code it's a masterpiece of prose so everything that i've been describing so he this is what he writes so the story of the cathars what is the cathars a saga of spiritual freedom and religious intolerance a warning and a lesson from the past always worth telling except of course that none of it is true. Oh, what a cliffhanger. the middle ages have believed and so what is what are peg's arguments what is he making what and he's not alone uh there are other historians as well who were making this case that actually the cathars as conventionally understood didn't actually exist if you would like to hear our second and third installments on the cathars right now then tom all they have to do is head to www.restishistorypod.com and sign up to our
这是一个问题。它当然能与《达·芬奇密码》媲美，是一部散文杰作。所以我一直在描述的这些——这就是他所写的：卡特尔派的故事，究竟什么是卡特尔派？是一部关于精神自由与宗教不容忍的传奇，是一个来自过去的警告和教训，永远值得讲述……当然，除了这些全都是假的。哦，真是个悬念。中世纪一直相信这些，那么佩格的论点是什么？他在表达什么？而且他并不孤单，还有其他历史学家也在提出这种观点，即传统意义上理解的卡特尔派实际上并不存在。如果你想现在就收听我们关于卡特尔派的第二和第三部分，汤姆，你所需要做的就是前往 www.restishistorypod.com 并注册加入我们的
members club where you can enjoy ad-free listening and early access to episodes. So we will return to try and solve the mystery of who were the Cathars, what do they believe, where do they come from? And then we will tell the story, or you will tell the story, of the extraordinarily bloody and dark Albigensian crusade against these people who did or didn't exist. The crusade definitely happened and thousands of people were definitely killed. So it's both a fascinating historical detective story and a riveting and blood soaked narrative. But Dominic, the thing, I mean, the thing that makes it so, so fascinating, I think, is that it is a story about conspiracies. It's a story about conspiracy theories. And although the Cathar, there is no Cathar church, in a sense, there are Cathars,
会员俱乐部，在那里你可以享受无广告收听和提前收听节目的特权。所以我们将回归，试图解开以下谜团：卡特尔派究竟是谁？他们信仰什么？他们从哪里来？然后我们将讲述——或者将由你来讲述——针对这些存在或不存在的人群展开的极其血腥和黑暗的阿尔比十字军东征的故事。十字军东征确实发生了，成千上万的人也确实被杀了。所以这既是一个迷人的历史侦探故事，又是一个扣人心弦且血腥的叙事。但多米尼克，最让人着迷的地方在于，我认为这是一个关于阴谋的故事。这是一个关于阴谋论的故事。尽管卡特尔派并没有一个真正的卡特尔派教会，从某种意义上说，确实有卡特尔派存在，
but they're not who you think they are. They're kind of, they're kind of, they're in plain view and they're not at all who you think they are. So, so I hope you'll tune in tomorrow. My mind is boggling. For, for a plunge into the thrilling and dark world of a medieval heresy. With renowned historian Tom Holland. See you tomorrow. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community,
但他们并不是你想象的那样。他们其实就在眼皮子底下，但完全不是你以为的那种人。所以，我希望你明天能继续收听。我的脑洞大开。一起深入探索中世纪异端的惊险与黑暗世界。与著名历史学家汤姆·霍兰一起。明天见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取更多加长节目、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。我们的会员俱乐部刚刚上线。如果你想要无广告收听、加长节目和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。